Hi, Marco. Good morning.
Good morning, Ira, how are you?
I'm good, I'm good. How about you? How was your long vacation?
Not long enough.
Is it five days, right? One week?
Yeah, yeah, I took the week, so I all last week I was away.
And.
Okay, did you have fun?
Yes, I did. So it was the entire last week, but since we had the Friday off the previous week, then it really was pretty cool. Oh, hey, I didn't know that you were going to connect.
Hey, hey, Miranda.
Hello, good morning.
Morning, thank you for joining.
I, I, I didn't think I didn't think you will connect since I was back.
The Pre.
I figured I would because my schedule is actually open right now at 11, so why not?
TA.
Gotcha.
All right, it's cool that both of you are here. So I'm just going to quickly share my screen. Let me know once you can see it, okay?
Mhm.
Thank you.
How are you, Miranda?
I'm well, how are you, Ayra?
I'm good. Totally fine. How was your weekend with your kids?
It was so nice. They had so much fun. They're off this whole week on their spring break from school, so they've been very busy and enjoying everything. Well, I've been working, but they're loving life.
Yeah.
That's good to hear that you enjoyed your time with your kids. I seem like to have a problem sharing here. One second. Let me try again.
Should be able to connect any minute soon. There you go. Finally. All right. Thank you, Marco and Miranda for joining our weekly service call. So today we're going to be reviewing last week's performance. For the agenda items, pretty much the same, no changes.
Yep, yep, I can see, yeah.
Yeah.
For this part, this is for you, team. How are things at this moment? Could you share a little feedback or any opportunities that we can work on?
Yeah, no, things are going okay. Jane is being shadowed right now. And I will double check. Well, I mean, technically I will have double checked tomorrow, but I'm going to be in a...
quarterly meeting all day tomorrow, so most likely either be some point towards the end of the day tomorrow, or if not Monday, I will be checking with my team to see if Jane may be in a stage of going solo without being shadow. If not, we'll shadow for at least one more week.
to two, but from the feedback that I'm getting from my team, things are going pretty well.
Perfect, perfect. As per our discussion last week with Miranda, I was able to address the CW manage. It seems like it's acting up whenever someone's connected to her screen. So what we did is to prevent that from happening because, you know,
when there's a lot of applications open, your laptop will act up. So we did try to access it from the web while someone's connecting to her computer or once someone's viewing her screen. So that seems to fix the issue. So sounds to me that everything's.
going well with train, but then if you have any feedback or urgent matter that needs to be addressed on locally, please do ping me. I'm always available on Teams. So perfect. Moving on to the action tracker, we have two. Thank you so much, Marco and Miranda, for
whitelisting her home network. So that's good. By the way, we're going to try that tomorrow, if that's fine with you. I heard from Jane that you were following up with her. If when she can try accessing her or when she can work from home so we can test her tools, right?
Right, because this was also, I'm assuming, me asking her to test it was from the email that...
I forget who was, was it Kam or was someone else in your office saying that there was going to be a strike for public transportation on the Philippines. So I was like, okay, well, you know, if she needs to work from home, which is fine, we just need to make sure that she can test it and make sure that it works.
Okay, perfect. Yeah, that's ongoing, the strike. So that's up until tomorrow. So we will try that and I'll probably ask her to log in one hour before her shift so we can make sure that she can still travel to the office. We can make arrangements for that if she can't. But I'm pretty sure that
She can, since we already whitelisted her home network. All right, for the second item, we need to remove the ITAR companies to Jane's manage. I was able to check in with her about that. And as of the moment, she can't see all of it.
So it should be good, right? Yeah.
She cannot. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So she cannot. So the problem, the only problem that she's having right now, which actually, since you are on the call, I am going to ask you to try this. You don't even need to log in. I just need you to see.
If you can access this website, because...
So, what I did, so...
The way that KinetWise works.
Once you block access to the, let's call it the ITAR companies.
What happens is she cannot see those companies at all, so...
which is kind of a problem. Ideally, in a search, it will have shown up, but then it will have told her, you don't have access. But since they don't show, then she doesn't even know that they accessed. But when she gets phone calls from those clients, she needs to be able to understand that they are client, it's just that they're not showing in your
In her connect wise, so...
We, you know, I know that you may have provided a list and all that stuff, but ideally it was like, as we are onboarding new clients and all that stuff, that list becomes dynamic.
So we had a report that was built for her to see, so dynamically it would change. The only problem is that...
She's having problems right now accessing that site. Now, nobody else seems to be having issues, and she is having the issue, whether it being not only just, let's say, you know, on your network, but she's also even having the...
problem even when she connects through the VPN. So on the chat, I just put a link. So if you have a minute, if you can click on that link, what should bring you up is to a page where you are requested to put your username and password.
I think I know this. Is it? Okay, she did actually reach out to me an hour ago. I was checking with her before our call. So she can't access this website wherein she can find all of the updated ITR companies and all of the stuff that she needs to know.
So I did check in and we did try making changes to her browser. So apparently she just needs to input her tab credentials. And after that, she was able to access it. So that's good for now.
So she, okay, so she was able to access it? Okay, that's good because she has not told me. And so I was, I wasn't sure. So I was like, I had had Rick from my end doing a bunch of stuff. So he has been, you know, doing a lot of things, including last night and.
Yeah.
And he messaged me earlier today and he's like, I don't know what's going on. And I'm like, don't worry, we'll figure it out. But that's why I was tossing this out in here to see if you were able to access it. But it seems like she's good now. So I'll circle back with her then.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I told her that I will tell you over this call because we have a service call. We just did fix it like an hour ago.
Yeah, so I just randomly checked all of her tools and apparently she's having issues. So Marco, when that happens, you can always reach out to me. You can ping me whenever you're having issues or whenever Jane's having issues accessing your tools so I can check
get real time for you.
Right, but I mean, the only reason I didn't reach out because I thought it was something to do with us because...
You're not right.
Because I was like, okay, I mean, there might be something that may have not been configured right on the firewall or anything like that. And that's ultimately, since I was going to have you on the call, I was like, okay, what about I have you guys test now, but since you're saying that it's working, then.
Then I'm good, so I understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
Okay, no worries. I'm just trying to give my hand here. So whenever you have issues, you can always ping me. I'm always available here on Teams. And also, I can't access this on my end. She needs to connect to her VPN.
so she can access it. Yeah, it's restricted outside your network.
I can't open it on my end.
So.
Okay, so the idea is that she should be able to do this without the VPN because it has the external access and that's why we open, that's why we open the our firewall to the Philippines office. So ideally, no, not ideally, she should not have to connect through the VPN to access that.
No.
And.
Portal.
Okay, so that I didn't check. Right now we're connecting to the VPN so she can access it. But then do I try, I'm trying right now, do I need to have a tab account or I can also access it even with my domain?
OK.
No, I said you would.
No, no, it will need a tab account, but ideally you should be able to access the site, like, you know, get to that position where it's prompting you with a username and password. So, okay, so, okay, so, yeah, so that should be fine. So it should work just fine.
Yeah, it is now. It's asking for credentials.
So she should not be, she shouldn't have to connect to the VPN.
Mhm.
Okay, we'll check that later after the call and I'll have her ping you.
Okay, perfect.
Okay, all right. Cool. So moving on to, so sorry, I can see that Natalie joined in. Hey, Natalie, good morning.
Hey, how's everyone doing?
Hey, Natalie.
Hi, Natalie.
I was just, I was getting back. I was at an event in Florida and then they sent the booth back, but the booth like didn't make it. So I'm tired today, man. It's just the event conference life, you know.
Yeah.
I hear you.
I have a question for you at the end of the of the call, well, you know, Ayra, please continue.
Okay, cool.
Okay, sure. So this will just be quick for the performance analysis because we don't have this data yet because she's not doing operational solo. So just a quick readiness update. So as mentioned, it's already the ITER companies.
It's already removed from Jane's ConnectWise Manage. Plus, we've already fixed the custom CW reports dashboard, so that's accessible now, but then I'll try doing it without the VPN. So I'll circle back on that.
one for the team GPS. So we're actually using this. This is one of our holy grails. So we use this for our quarterly review. They're using it. OK, perfect. So you're doing your quarterly review.
That Ayra, that they used to, they used to GPS.
on this one, Marco.
The quarterly review, I believe, is next week, Tuesday, Natalie, if that's right.
No, no, she's saying, are you doing, have you started doing like your guys' quarterly assessments through that? It's fresh on our mind because all of our quarterly assessments are due.
Are you doing it here? Yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing it right now.
Oh.
Yeah.
We have team GPS, but it's not implemented just yet. So we're not using any piece of it, but it'll be our upcoming quarter. We should have many of the items implemented at tab.
It.
No.
Yeah.
Okay, okay. That's good. That's good.
Okay, gotcha. It's pretty cool. It's user-friendly. So, all right, if you have questions on this one, we have like a product manager on this one. We can help you with that. Plus the
So no, we are working with the team GPS team, but just so you are aware, the performance aspect of it and the KPIs, that's not part of this initial rollout. So you won't be able to see any metrics for her in there because we're not going to have any metrics for anyone in there because it's not something that we're going to be implementing.
Mhm.
At least not now.
Is it it's just not it's not in the first part of the rollout, but it'll eventually be we put that in there because it is convenient.
Uh...
The eventually part, I'm going to let Miranda answer that. I am just more like the, I don't know, the one. Okay, I was about to say something that was really bad, so I'm not going to say it. I'm just the one that puts the brick in the wall and that's it.
There you go. No, I would just say with that performance management piece, it does make it really nice. And especially if you guys are going to be running like even your L10s and stuff like that, you want to get those integrations set up because then everything's automated from your tools right into these meetings. So you don't have to manually enter data all the time.
Okay, cool. But then if you need help, there's Natalie. You can always ping her. Moving on to other products that we offer, so I'll send you this deck. So if you have questions or if you're interested on one of these, you can always reach out to us. For the way forward,
So yeah, in continuation for the IP whitelisting, I'll have Jane work from home tomorrow. So I'll give you feedback on that one if there's anything blocked. Plus, also, she's requesting for a PDO this coming September. So it's going to be 3 days.
Would you like me to send you the email for this one so you can review? It's pretty far, but then she wanted to make sure, because she's traveling abroad.
Yeah, me having that information as soon as possible is the best because I will put it in the system. So lucky enough for her right now, since
Yeah.
Pre much, this is going to be a brand new team.
I don't think anyone else is going to be on vacation during that time.
But that is one of those things that I need to look to make sure that I have enough people before I approve vacation.
Okay, I'll send you the email so you can decide, okay?
All right, so that's the end of this slide. Thank you guys for listening. Any questions, any feedback you want to say?
No, I mean, like I said, things are working so far okay. The feedback from the different CSRs that have worked with her is that she's doing well, you know, she seems pretty eager, and I mean...
Okay.
Right.
That's a good thing so far.
Okay, thank you for the feedback. Let me just stop sharing my screen so we can have a discussion. All right, you want to talk about the thing that you want to say to Natalie?
Yeah, it has nothing to it has nothing to do with Jane at all, and so Natalie, I think it was maybe a couple days ago I sent an email to...
Yeah.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't know, I guess the BuildIt people, I guess. You know, the email came in through Kam, I guess, and I replied, and I know that it went to, I guess, somewhere in there. But I haven't gotten a response, and all I'm trying to do is, how can I register my people? Well, the people I register, how can I assign them?
Yeah, Aneja.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, let me look because I...
Yeah, no, so I...
Yeah, I had a little chain going like on the back end too, because she had responded that like you were registered and then I was like, but he has the four pack. Like, so I'm like, so we need to add other people to that. So let me see if I even had a response there. But yeah, I'll work on that on the back end just to make sure that you're getting the right.
Everybody's getting signed up there.
Okay, yeah, and I think on the email I specify the people's name.
Okay, okay, so you and you send it over to that as well. Okay.
It was on that email, so yeah, I don't...
I'll tell you in a second who we went to. I don't send that many emails, so...
It.
The.
Miranda, can can?
Do you wanna do you wanna you can reply all and loop me into it if you want to as well.
What?
The thing is, I it was it went to build it live at ITBD.net.
Okay.
And then I, I don't think I have, I don't think I heard anything from anyone after that.
Yeah, it's normally goes to Nikki, yeah.
Okay, let me look into it. I'll see.
But I, what I can do is I can forward you this now.
If.
If there is a change of like, hey, you know, maybe, you know, this person doesn't want to go in and we need to transfer it to someone, is that okay?
Yeah, yeah, we can still do it. We can transfer it. You guys have the tickets, so you guys can put a different name on it until up until the show if you need to. But yeah, we'll at least get who you have now.
Okay, I can.
Can we put on Ticketmaster and resell them? Given that I bought it for a preferential price and now it's like they're like free 300 bucks.
No, no.
I mean, I guess, I mean, I guess, I guess technically you could. If you want to put a markup on it, you could do that. If you want to start selling tickets at a higher price, I'll just let you know. You can just sell, sell tickets.
Right here in business.
Yeah, that's right. Always, always doing it. And then I think, did you end up interviewing that other candidate that we sent the resume over for?
Yeah, so I interviewed them. I think, oh, I think I was talking to Andy. So just a little funny tidbit. We didn't take the candidate. We ended up finding a local candidate. But one funny tidbit that happened in the two interviews in there, and it was totally, I guess, on me without realizing that
there was a cultural difference in terms of what I was asking, because when I asked, when I asked them, it's like, hey, can you tell me about yourself? I was expecting to hear about themselves professionally, but they started telling me about their lives and, you know, they have this many kids and, you know, what TV show they liked.
Oh, God, I'll leave it, man.
Yeah.
The first interview I was scratching my head, I was like, what is going on in here? And then it happened, it happened again. I was like, okay, I need to stop asking that question that way.
Abe.
Oh, no, no, yeah, I mean, yeah, people like to talk about themselves. Now you got to learn a little bit, a little bit more. Yeah, someone probably need to mix in the professional up there too, right?
It was great.
Yep.
Cool, cool, cool. So you already hired somebody for the position, so it doesn't sound like right now. So right now we'll just focus on. Does she go by Jane? Is that what we're deciding on?
But that's not what we decided, that's what she decided.
Yes.
Okay, so yeah, we could change the service call here because our name is Marie on here as well. So yeah, we'll change it to Jane so it's not confusing. Most of Zoom for me, I'm confused by it.
Yeah.
Well, it's very confusing because in our system, you know, it is the proper name. So it's Marie, Marie J, and then Nunez, but, you know, you're like, oh, talk to Jane. Oh, you can't find Jane. You have to look for Marie.
Okay, gotcha.
Gotcha, gotcha. Okay, well then should we keep the name as Marie?
But it doesn't matter. I mean, we know who we're talking about.
Abe.
Maybe we'll just put Marie, we'll put Marie Jane.
Yeah, MJ.
There we go. Solved. Case solved. All right, cool.
Yeah, it's good to have options.
Or you can call her like Miranda used to call her June.
Yeah, and there you go.
Mary Jane June. There we go. Anyway, she was pretty flexible.
Yeah.
So, what?
PH.
There we go. That's good.
Anyways, anyways, any feedback? Are you good, everyone? No other questions pending?
Yeah, good. Nope.
Okay, but then if you have increased, if you're having issues with the chain with her access, please feel free to send me an email or you can ping me here on Teams, okay?
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
All right, thank you so much, Michael, Rana, and Natalie for joining this. Have a good one. Bye.
See ya.
Alright, bye.
Thanks. Bye. Have a good day.